good morning Millennials happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday it's funny how that generic
version but became the real version
sweeping the nation and that's what the
creators of the happy birthday song get
for being so [ __ ] greedy and like
whatever this is licensing you can't
sing it's a Stevie Wonder came in here
saving lives saving birthdays better oh
my god yes like heart and jazz and
there's also um like a verse it's like
I'm at Savannah Mae
oh yeah a matinee it came on well I
walked into my party last night and at
first I was like I just thought it was
the Stevie Wonder song and then it
launches into happy birthday so it's
like a stealth happy birth no it's also
just [ __ ] jam
it's a [ __ ] Jam um hey everyone it's
my birthday 27 years young today what's
good do you feel any older now I've
actually been talking about like my
birthday and uh I'm a late baby so like
I didn't in New York like the cut-offs
December so I was the youngest in my
grade so all my friends have been 27 for
years now and it made me feel like I was
already 27 so now just turning 27 I'm
like oh I'm only 27 and I'm the same age
as Theo
that's no true young is according to his
dog DNA test test kit they said in human
years he's 27 he's so young and youthful
looking so it's like oh if I look like
him I'm Gucci yeah I know there's just
something about birthdays like not to
upset you but it's just like so sad yeah
of course like racing towards my death
no exactly it's like Vicki Gunvalson
jake'd like now now you're gonna start
crying when people start referencing
your funeral yeah very very sad but you
know what's something interesting last
year I remember I said on the show no
one called me at midnight and that's
when you know you're getting old over
your friends oh sure wait up until
midnight to call you but I got two calls
on midnight the first one was Becky she
called me right at 12 o'clock and she
said I called you because I remember you
said last year that no no and she said
that I always call her I mean I didn't
even know that I'd do that I feel like
I'm the worst round I'm the worst friend
and then Dana called me she was two
minutes late but she got it in well I
texted I figured you didn't want to be
called I know I was midnight except
maybe you were like lovemaking
Zak's given you his birthday suit not on
the dot at midnight I was still watching
Real Housewives
I did watch I did phenomenal we will
recap it
we wonderful show to you for you guys
today in addition to celebrating the
life that is Jackie O let's play a
little game before we type in I love
birthday games oh and I also we need to
talk about my party last night because
of what went on on my Instagram like
people were dying Jacqueline was
convinced that we were throwing her a
surprise party well here's the thing I
didn't want a surprise party I just want
to make that clear like I wasn't getting
my hopes up like if you guys would threw
me a surprise party like I'd be pissed
and then I what I would have to drink
like and socialize but I was just
singing like very suspect you throw a
game night at your house the night
before my birthday like how is that not
gonna be like it was a perfect setup for
a surprise party also today is your
birthday and I'm literally gonna not see
you again after this because I'm going
to Morocco I have a million things to do
but I felt really guilty that like I
wasn't gonna be here for your birthday
dinner like your birthday in general
like we take birthdays really seriously
in our family so I figured I would throw
like a game night the night before and
like get you a cake you know like it was
a nice way to spend time with the family
before ly for my trip celebrate you um
but you know me like once I start doing
one thing I like had to get balloons and
cake and like then I was like whatever
it's like a birthday party like a party
it's Bertha and I guess like technically
it was a party that was a surprise
because you thought you were just coming
for gravy night but it was still game
night you know nobody want to play any
[ __ ] games it was still gaming up
then I almost felt like you were gonna
be disappointed so your friends were
texting me they were like are we coming
and I'm like no [ __ ] do you want to know
I wasn't gonna be disappointed I really
only wanted to hang out with my family
and by the way if I really thought it
was a surprise party I wouldn't have put
it all over insert horn attracts okay
and I wouldn't have worn attracts okay
you know like I wouldn't actually have
ruined my own surprise yeah and then
someone was like because someone
messaged me saying that I hate game
night so like why would you do game
night before my birthday and someone was
like cringing that I posted that but
it's like everyone on this show knows
that I hate she makes kids eyes like I
was crushing charades and the reason why
I hate games is that like I get too
involved it's like a love-hate
relationship and but we only play trades
which is my favorite game because most
of you get to sit on the couch
that's so funny it's literally my least
favorite game and it's like the only
game people on our family can tolerate
but last night was just such a joy and
made me realize well I was getting ready
and pentagons
home and I like alliterated all the work
everything was all set up he was like
sitting on the couch watching me like
slave over the oven you know and he's
like I want this for my birthday I'm
like shut up like you [ __ ] selfish
I'm like I'm busy like and then I was
like you know what actually I do want
this for my birthday too but like not at
my house I'm gonna make a little yeah do
it or I'll do it I love a taco party and
I got all the questions about where the
food was from because like you know my
ass doesn't cook major shout-out to
parkis kosher butcher who catered the
entire thing for me for a very
reasonable price and that is not [ __ ]
sponsored I just want to say I ordered
it like 12 hours in advance and they
showed up the guy delivered so much what
I thought I was gonna die like but
literally but if you're looking about
getting into podcast sponsorships like
we do have inventory available yeah and
we do love a parkis kosher moment we do
and this shredded chicken I had never
had it before I sent everyone home with
a little Tupperware yeah which by the
way I'm gonna need back it was like all
my Tupperware okay we'll go back to I'm
actually really good about getting
people stuff I guess I could just like
buy more but like really lose your
Tupperware I'm really good about getting
pepper right back oh this is definitely
27 year olds conversation because also
it's cuz I don't cook so everyone's
always like giving me leftovers and I
appreciate it so much I don't want you
to regret it yeah I want you to do it
again so Before we jump in let's play a
little birthday game I love a birthday
yesterday we all went around and said
one nice thing about Jackie people don't
really follow the rules what Jake is
nice but I just like rules are there for
a reason they're they're there so we
have more fun um tomorrow let's play a
game just like you and I let's play like
what is our favorite memory of Jackie in
her 26 years 20 60 years yes I know
these are so bad okay I didn't go over
like my year for you okay Mary that was
a really big one oh I have mine oh okay
what do I pepper this camp bump bump
bump bump bump bump bump Oh boom what
the memory Italian camper at her wedding
yeah Nixon what do I pack for this camp
that was really that was a highlight of
my year as well yeah um I want to say
that the highlight of your 26 year was
us at the CMA Awards that was May 25th
oh no that was the week after May 26th
here yeah it was 26 because um we looked
so beautiful both of us like we both
used pictures from that day like as our
headshots I think for our podcast this
problem is so like I was so happy and so
excited I'm feeling so beautiful that I
was smiling too big you know so there's
a lot of the stuff like my smiles too
big yeah so this year I'm just gonna be
more koi so that was just a great day
for us because like we looked so
beautiful we did such a good job so many
funny things came out of that step into
a new land Caleb who put the chocolates
in his pocket like just so many funny
memories and also it was like the first
like really big partnership we got after
being cancelled with a really big toast
moment and we were just like oh we're
not no one still thinks we're recess cuz
we're not yeah so it's a great day for
us that that's always a great day yeah
so I would say I would say that only
because nothing else is really coming to
mind yeah no it was pretty standard year
but yeah you know it was actually above
average year I guess cuz it got married
but I was early and then it's over I
didn't got married like you grew your
business you became a real entrepreneur
sure but I do think that like 26 was one
of my better years I got 25 was rocky I
remember but obviously yeah but 20 like
I really thoroughly enjoyed this year
but then it makes me think that 27 sight
can be like it's on and off you know
well my even years are better than my
odd years here is that myth in Hollywood
another word we're coming you know part
of Hollywood's elite about the 27 club
like some people don't make it yeah some
people don't make it because they like
turned to drugs and alcohol um that's
not you you can't even drink that
chapter of my life is is over so it
wasn't like the 21 club I just feel like
my um like the chapter of my life like
should be coming to a close but like a
day you know you're not 27 so it's time
I know when you were 25 like it was very
much starting to us no I mean 26
birthday we had a party at this
speakeasy and then I was so [ __ ]
hungover still drunk went to the
football game I literally was looking at
my time having these pictures of me like
in the nosebleeds had a football game
like so [ __ ] drunk eating a hot dog
like and like posing for pictures like I
think I'm [ __ ] yeah Irina Shayk
kendall Jenner and like one eye closed
one eye open hotdog and like so [ __ ]
high up and you know I was drunk because
I would never sit that high up on my own
I got it I know you were drugged because
you're into a football game right you
shared birthday with Kris Jenner week
yeah I share birthday with Sally Field
I'm sure sherbert they would take a lot
of new celebrities they only know my
birthday but buddy from who was famous
when I was in second grade Jessica
Simpson so if you're like an influencer
now and your birthday's are over six
like I don't know oh let's play a fun
game have you ever been on the website
famous birthday I believe them there you
have on it yet seem very really good job
of keeping up like they're always
emailing like looking for some
interesting facts and
stuff okay let's see the answer but it's
I appreciate that what number you're at
like there's a lot of people whose
birthdays oh my god everyone thinks you
can't drink because you're pregnant oh
no she just can't drink if she came as
hell we address this to you guys like
Kelly brothers I did not drink and not
be pregnant like we don't have to be
such beasts yeah either drinking or
pregnant you guys the most famous person
who has a birthday today
is a girl named Lauren Orlando and she's
15 years old does anyone know her no
okay so you are on here the twenty four
thousand eight hundred and forty eighth
most popular birthday and but with the
name Jackie you're the sixteenth most
popular birthday Oh pretty cool you are
a member of 27 year olds you and Selena
Gomez you're a member of the group
Instagram stars you and James Charles
first name Jackie you and Jackie Chan
born in New York you and cardi B wow
that's a really cool Club where's Jackie
Evancho oh I'm sure she's number one I
told you know the story story so last
week I got into an uber after the show
and my name I might you buries Jackie
I'm sorry I just took my night want to
say like I'm the 12,000 most famous
person in the world like wow you're
double as famous as need because I'm
sure 3/4 now but I'm the old jack am
only the 36 month me the most famous
person more on July 10th
oh but with the name Claudia number 7
open tomorrow
Odom's birthday Wow everyone's going in
ethan hawke oh yeah I knew that um not
Tony Hawk oh the most most famous
according to Bob this is crazy if you
either would have asked you who's the
most famous person with a name Claudia
obviously besides me Claudia Schiffer
right you know who it is Claudia so
loose key because she's unmuted today
Claudia so loose key is the number one
most famous Claudia according to
people's birthdays calm and Claudia
loose key who you guys know is beautiful
influencer to the Stars also dating
Phineas Eilish Billy I delicious mother
it's weird because she looks just like
Billy Eilish she's unborn Elizabeth's
new podcast mood with Lauren Elizabeth
they did like an eight girl episode
where they're both just talking about
like how fabulous skinny and trendy they
are and I really couldn't relate to a
lesson no kidding it's a great episode
to know I'm so Satan listen I hope she
answered my question that I left did you
leave a question yes I said how does it
feel but you're always things like said
that you look like you're in France it's
okay I'm sure it's so annoying right it
was look kind of gross yeah it looks so
similar it's a weird thing wow he's tell
your Jackie Evancho story and then we
went ahead to the past five okay so I
got into my uber last week a key in my
uber and I was sitting in the guy was
like Jackie
yeah yeah he was like you know Jackie
Evancho and I was like oh yeah like I
know her um he was like she's so great
and he said he was like when I saw
Jackie I was like maybe Jackie Evancho
turns out I'm in the car with Jackie van
chosen number one he was talking who's
playing some of her performances for me
apparently she played my heart will go
on for the troops Wow really beautiful
and he was just like I think he was
disappointed that I wasn't Jackie Jo um
it was literally she was on America's
Got Talent she was like a very young
girl who was like an opera singer and
she sings like she does stuff like
Stevie Wonder she's a beautiful
rendition of someday a Christian look at
Josh Groban yes she's just a child
prodigy yeah she is a beautiful really
talented singer so he's obviously a man
of fine taste but he like [ __ ] hate
random like so when I heard the story I
just thought it was so [ __ ] random
and funny like it's hilarious it's
really they got Jackie nachos number one
fan like imagine how disappointed he was
no I know
and it's like he's driving around the
big city like just waiting to make up
Jackie Evancho I'm like on her prostate
I'm like maybe when he saw me like in
that coming out of the building like I'm
her same height probably the way you
dressed like a child like right he was
probably like Jackie's event you might
have because one day last week oh no it
was the day that I got into your uber
and then I had to get out and get in
mind remember that day no crazy day
okay well I do believe what do you think
I think it's time because you know we'll
go in and out I was just talking about
me and my legacy your legacy is big so
without further ado it's time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's time
don't get me wrong it is one hundred
percent time but you know what else it
is time for the holidays yes it is joy
to the [ __ ] world y'all you can
spread more joy with custom holiday
cards calendars photo gifts from
vistaprint to me and then I've actually
decided for the first time we're gonna
send out holiday cards we always talk
about it but we don't have a picture
that we like and off like that we both
can agree on just send a picture of Theo
but actually I'm we had Anthony Vasquez
take a couple pics of us the last time I
saw him and they were like kind of glam
and like very like holiday spirit E so
we're gonna send out holiday cards and
it's like okay I'm a 25 year old what do
I do I want to send out holiday cards
like where this is Brant guess what you
can pick a shape like around square
corners folder or flat choose one of
these two prints they've got literally
one
designs they've got everything from fun
to festive to gorgeous eye catching
looks you can then choose your favorite
picture right there on most of the
options and even upload a great shot
right from your phone while we're so
millennial then just figure out how many
you need order them with time to spare
now it's hard for me because I have like
three friends and like five family
members looks like I'll be needing eight
cards mr. Breen has hundreds of card
designs from timeless classics to find
new trends they also have custom
calendars for gifts oh I'm they give Ben
a calendar with like sexy pics of me on
every Wow Merry Christmas for him
that's so cool I'm all custom cards and
calendars are up to 50% off right now
you can also upload your favorite photos
right from your phone
save on mugs canvases and other gifts
it's actually really cute gift idea your
satisfaction is 100% guaranteed or
they'll make it right either by
reprinting your order or offering you a
refund so this season make more merry at
vistaprint.com with up to 15% off all
holiday cards and photo calendars plus
great deals on photo gifts at Vistaprint
comm just enter promo code toast 50
that's vistaprint.com promo code toast
50 TOA st number five and number zero
the offer expires january 5th so get
your holidays together sign on and be
cheerful yeah I love that I love a good
holiday card it's like what's more adult
than sending out holiday cards cuz
you're not an adult these kids anyone
took colgate with they send out with a
holiday card every year they like it's
really cute every year he asked me for
my address and I'm like I'm like
actually he didn't ask me this year his
ain't the season okay first story I'm
Isaiah I'm literally so obsessed with
this first story that I'm reading it
from top to bottom because Kim
Kardashian planned the most incredible
birthday for her mom okay before you do
that I have to tell you the most insane
[ __ ] thing someone tweeted at me
yesterday okay okay just give me two
seconds talk about yourself so you wait
do you want me to go into the story but
no you said before you do that oh oh
wait but what was it this girl was like
the morning toast has turned into a show
sponsored by the Kardashians and Kanye
West's like I [ __ ] wish and I am
upset and visibly others are too I
[ __ ] wish I wish like bye [ __ ] and
also like I love all the twisters Blake
if you don't like like the Kardashians
why you listen to the shut up and then
this isn't the place for you yeah I
really wish I so much every day I love
them more and I could talk about them
for all five stories seem and I spent by
the way after another story after what
Kim did for clothes for her birthday
like I will never not stand them so
[ __ ] hard so [ __ ] hard I want to
tell you guys just in case you don't
know so yesterday was Kris Jenner's
birthday Kim posted a picture of the
sisters in a vintage Mercedes to her
Instagram with the caption
today we celebrate my mom anyone that
knows her knows how sentimental she is
for her birthday I planned a small lunch
with just her kids and her closest
friends of 40-plus years I sent out
invites with a location where we all met
when everyone arrived I told them I had
a surprise and this wasn't where we
would be eating I then gave everyone the
real invitation and once we saw the
address for where we would be for where
would be we would be going tears filled
the room I rented our childhood home all
of our memories live here especially
with our dad it's where each Kardashian
child was born and made us who we are
growing up the home had the most
ridiculous wallpaper in kitchen said I
remade all of our table settings Dacor
out of the same fabric and print as the
wallpaper we had lunch at the home as if
it hadn't changed and we cried the
entire time when we walked out to get
our cars to drive there I had another
surprise I had rented every car my
parents ever owned I had some waiting
outside so we could drive them to the
house and the rest were lined up in the
driveway of the house exactly how my
parents used to have them parked
I even remade the exact license place
yes my mom had a to die for it license
plate we drove to the home in these cars
and relived our childhood this was um
this was the best day ever I am so proud
I was able to keep such a meaningful
surprise a secret from my mom and my
sisters for weeks this was the most
special nostalgic day of my life and we
felt my dad's presence enjoying this day
with us I kept it together and didn't
cry the entire lunch even though I cried
during the entire planning process but
at the end I went into my old bathroom
closed the door and cried so hard we're
gonna cry like this is so sweet and I
think like I buy the right not that I
think I'm I crash am but I really times
so hard like imagine it's like for your
birthday I rented the house we grew up
in it would be it would be like almost
like sad anybody peak of life and I feel
like every year that kris has had the
biggest birthdays and so you go from
like having normal birthdays just game
night at your sister's house like these
extravagant Affairs trips etc and then
you got to a point like you can't top it
and you just go back to the beginning
and it must have been so beautiful one
for like the whole family just to relive
that
and I feel the spirit of their dad and -
I feel like for Kim you know going to
the bathroom where she probably used to
like look in the mirror and tell herself
that she's gonna go to Davis and to like
not only have achieved that but so much
like wilder than any child's imagination
totally you should not even dream up the
success that Kim Kardashian is oh right
cuz she's famous she's a businesswoman
she's a mama for opposing life she's a
philanthropist she's an activist she's
literally gonna be President one day
literally and I think that's beyond her
wildest dreams so I just feel like it
was a full moment you know you don't
often get times just like reflect on
your life but that's just like one of
those times no it's so crazy this sounds
like what I saw when I was reading the
caption I got such chills like what
first of all what a creative birthday
gift because when you're so rich and
like all you do is have cars and bags
and planes like sometimes it's hard to
like feel fulfilled by like material
things so like I totally get why Kris is
so like latches on like sentimental
items like what you got Cortney that
Disney thing like the more meaningful
gifts um and this is so creative and so
sweet and like I just now I want to go
back to our house no shame or like rent
out the country club because they won't
let us in so yeah because we got denied
but we should like just rent it for an
event like you could get it for a
wedding time a birthday party I never
leave that would be amazing
I just like I just have questions about
the logistics yes nobody lived there
okay so she said the house isn't for
sale but she was able to rent it I'm
sure if it's if it's not on the market
like for rent she probably gave them an
offer they couldn't refuse
you know if someone owns it and if
someone owned by the way it's my house
and like I used to live here
give me $20,000 so let me like sit spend
the afternoon bye-bye let me pick my
berry so actually if it's Kim Kardashian
right yeah so I bet the fact that she
could rent it um I thought she did buy
it for a second then I was like damn
these people have too much money but I
do wish they they did own it because in
a lot of ways it's like it's a landmark
like it's a part of history and the fact
that they don't own it or go there like
it's kind of crazy like it was on so
many seasons it's not I don't think that
was the one because it said all the
Kardashians were born there so it was
where Kris lived with Robert the ranch
house was where Kris lived with Bruce so
when she said the Kardashians were born
did she not mean Kylie and Kendall yeah
she did not mean kind of okay okay oh
yeah so it's like their first verse so
do you like that's going to our our
yes house crazy oh this actually gives
me a really good idea okay um this is
just so sweet I like live for this is
such a beautiful and everyone copies
with the Kardashian does like you know
everything that they wear everything
like that they do and buy and go and
it's like we should also copying this
just nostalgia you know and like making
people happy like this is so sweet like
I actually cried when I read the caption
again just gasp got it and I wanna dress
a bit of fake news that's going around
in the comments yeah commented that
someone in one of the groups admitted
that they emailed Claudia the Kanye West
thing because the lyrics were already
leaked before also whoever this is keeps
keeps recommending it because she wants
everyone to see it and it's fake news
guys we don't care literally no but like
she's putting it out there I just want
to say like I'll go back for you that's
not what we're not putting things out
there now okay I'm a supermodel well
that's already true so true
like I don't need validation from anyone
I got an email from someone at easy
doctor home but if y'all give me my
source is trying to like pretend like
who it is I one day I know I have a name
in my head yeah and keeps commenting it
because someone keeps commenting that
someone else did that oh but you guys
this is the thing when you're like so
successful I'm beautiful like people are
trying to come for you and you know what
you Connie had a special moment and no
one can take that away from me grab a
spoon and eat my big fat ass thank you
have a great day don't forget to put
salt ketchup and mustard delicious also
some food kylie got chris a diamond
burger took a [ __ ] no literally like
this is the type of gift we're like no
material item could ever compare yeah
it's really so beautiful and i just i
love them more and more every to low to
share that story and that's all i have
to say okay next story in today's
edition of Jeffrey Epstein did not kill
himself because we've been ABC News
response to the ami war Bach video and
says that the Epstein accuser interview
wasn't ready for air oh wait I'm sorry
so this person who is claiming that they
sent me the easier today also send me
two pairs of Easy's let me know let me
know because also if you did like could
you send me two pairs of you just have
like Yeezys lying around
continue I'm sorry thank you so we've
all seen now that interview the yeah
video that leaked yesterday of the ABC
News anchor talking about how this story
the Jeopardy I've seen story was quashed
years ago by ABC News and by the palace
okay a the palace she's hot miked even
though a part of me thinks that she
knows she was on and was pretending that
she didn't know so I think she was
between clips you know like we sometimes
we just sit here and we talk it wasn't
airing but then someone got the clip oh
it didn't air live no just like it love
the little mole who leaked it I think so
this was I got leaky vibe no no it said
that an ABC person like Lydia good good
for this is so crazy
and when I first heard that ABC News was
the one who who put a halt to the story
when she had she has she got an
interview with one of Epstein's um
victims like she had pictures like the
girl said it was a mother in most
endeavor Julia Roberts and she's been
one of the most outspoken victims
so she said it was one of the most
in-depth interviews like she's ever had
and when I heard ABC News put a can on
it I'm like okay some executive at ABC
News like used to touch little boys on a
plane used to take a ride on the Lolita
Express right and so then when I heard
it was Buckingham Palace I was like
these Shaddai better in was like losers
I just can't like Megan Marco could not
stand for this no she cannot um
and now ABC News is saying like the
interview didn't meet standards like
yeah but I've seen some low-level
interviews on ABC those meet the
standards excuse me I was on ABC okay
the news anchor is like backtracking to
you she wants of course and you know
what she I'm here for her backtracking
like I know she literally spelled it all
out for us she gave us everything that
we needed now she's gonna step away
that's fine thank you for your service
yeah I'm a question like where's the
interview somewhere in the bone Oh
ABC News is coming out with like a
documentary and a podcast about like
their coverage of Jeffrey Epstein saga
oh my god yeah so hypocritical no but I
guess it's gonna be I mean I hope it's
about like why it only came out when I
don't know but I hope there are some
answers there's not going to be and it's
like a podcast really money just come on
the toast this is again like the Jeffrey
Epstein saga like the most powerful
people in the world like just lying and
being hypocrites and like
changing the narrative so that they like
so they just tell the public what they
want the public to think what it's like
not at all what happened right we're
never gonna find the truth about Jeffrey
Epstein because the people are involved
are so high up in government in business
in the world that like there's no way
they're ever gonna let it get out right
oh that's why he quote-unquote killed
himself
Liz high made an excellent point that
the news anchor probably doesn't want to
be suicided as well but true yes
very good call but in just the past 24
or 48 hours there have been so many
memes now Jeff oh my god it does not get
less funny it does not get less funny we
are all on the same page and I'm happy
to see it they finally maybe a little
justice will be served
maybe yeah a small way yeah it's like
we'll never really get like a trial of
whether or not Jeffrey Epstein killed
himself but like the fact that everyone
in the world knows that he did it like
makes me feel good and these are like
the only upsides of like the internet
yeah everyone is going against what
everyone is telling us it's like we know
you're lying to us yeah we're going to
tell you that we know right but that
never have ever it's cool totally it's
cool okay are you ready for our next
story something so interesting because
Emma Watson is interviewed of British
Vogue I'm just hanging out with Irish
camper thanks a lot
and there's a lot Rachel thanks a lot I
hope you're happy because a told mom she
said I'm very happy being single I call
it being self partnered and of course
this is the quote that is now sweeping
the nation self partnering thoughts
people are praising her it's reminding
me of when Greta Paltrow said conscious
uncoupling ever and label turned like a
white supremacist when she was just like
a little out of touch but now Emma
Watson Sue Ann is like yes female
empowerment like if if justice is not
gonna be served here for crimes Paltrow
like I can't get on board no like that
plagued Quetta like her reputation like
took a hit and it never recovered until
recently like I think it should have the
same should happen for amma
yeah so she said i've never believed the
whole I'm happy being single SH appeal
I'm very happy being single I call it
self partnered um yeah I don't know I
just like I don't have it no it's like
at some point like single is not meant
to be like a derogatory like it's
literally just a fact you know yeah I'm
either
in a pair or I'm a single right so it's
so silly to like rebrand that word
because to me there's nothing wrong with
words the word single there's wrong
it's so funny the way that they're like
talking about this I just pulled up a
page six article it's like and though
Watson says she's coin a self empowered
term the concept of dating yourself are
getting even more serious has been
around for ages yes it started when Sue
Sylvester married Sue Sylvester yes in
season three of Glee yes but it's like
if this were Gweneth right no it's just
like there's different standards for
different people and I get that Emma
Watson is like you know the toast of
Hollywood and I'm happy for her but it's
like we're gonna make fun of Gwen it's
like we have to make fun of Emma and I'm
that's exactly what I'm gonna do yeah no
but it's like no one will make fun of
her this is just like such like a lame
thing that like only like an actress I'm
sorry only a white actress would say
like it's so lame like conscious
uncoupling what is it Sam your partner's
like meet you're single okay like this
is ashamed of so snitch yeah it spot
over here are you single or are you self
partnered I'm single I'm not self
partnered harder just sounds like you
masturbate a lot I think no self smarter
it sounds like you've fully given up
hope on ever finding yeah it's like
there's nothing wrong with being single
like why are we now like making it seem
like it's a bad thing no no it's great
to be single I'm changing the word
single to self partner it it's like you
should be ashamed of being single what a
dumb thing to say shame to being single
as if like the word single is negative
so you need to come up with a positive
term for it like it's not negative
whatsoever and single is Oh being single
is all about your attitude like you can
either be like single and it's like the
most the coolest thing ever or you're
like single and it's the saddest things
how you carry yourself about how you
decide to handle that is so beautifully
said you know because I mentioned that
like single people I was talking to
someone I was time switch recently I was
talking I won't Club her spot but I was
talking to a friend recently and she was
single and I was listening to her and
she just had the best attitude about it
right she that goes out on these dates
she set up she goes on um dating updates
but she also just like goes where like
takes her and so she was just like found
herself on the roof at the Guggenheim
because she just followed who um I
didn't want to over it's just in case
because like I don't know
I'll tell you after um and it was just
like cool to hear but sometimes you've
talked to single people and it's [ __ ]
depressing yeah because you're just
waiting for their life to start when
Amanda shows up at their door I don't
know how life works
no you have to roll up to the Guggenheim
and then like me no but it's also like
the people who Margo said it perfectly
the people who think that their life
doesn't start until they're in a
partnership with a man or a woman like
they think that they're not complete
until they're a pair like that's the
wrong mindset to be in you know yeah I
just don't think there's anything wrong
with being single like there's not I
like it Marta loves because I literally
love being single like it's like the
difference between being alone and
lonely yeah that's just such a wordsmith
today like I love being alone I love and
I'm not lonely sorry I actually hate
being alone I'm afraid of the dark and
you know
okay what about alone with C oh oh oh my
god there's nothing better nothing
compares nothing compares okay well emma
watson' good luck out there yeah good
luck and maybe give guests stone a
chance see and that's it all comes back
to that because only she she didn't she
wrote him off so quickly because you
think she's too good for anyone but
herself
right and it's like Gaston had had it
all going on and then one two three
Gaston
I think that was actually what we
competed are a perfect harmony yeah
because I went really low okay this next
story is a last-minute addition by
snitch um and I'm really excited because
Kristen Stewart says she would have
married Robert Pattinson Chuck I wish oh
my god wait what a different time what
was that what you were telling me about
angels no the Netflix movie oh holiday
in the wild but keep seeing all the
pressur they're doing kristen and Rob
and I'm like Stewart and Pattinson
they're back together because it's
Kristin Davis and Rob Lowe and I'm like
oh my god but then it's not but then
it's not Kristen Stewart is reflecting
on her romance with rot Robert Pattinson
the actress who was just 18 when she was
thrust into the spotlight I mean the
Twilight craze is opening up about her
relationship with the paparazzi and how
that scrutiny impacted her romance with
the former co-star in a new interview
with Howard Stern who carried to read it
in his next book Stewart explains how
she's been constantly followed by
photographers since she was teenager
calling the paparazzi thieves discussing
her relationship with Pattinson during
the height of the Twilight pandemonium
she says they wanted to quote keep it
ours and struggled over whether to share
their romance openly or put it on lock
but then you deprive yourself of so many
experiences she explains on the Howard
Stern Show we didn't walk down the
street holding hands because we were
like we don't want to give it to him but
then we didn't get to walk down the
street holding hands and it sucked later
on in the interview Stern notes that he
believes falling in love on set is the
biggest mistake but Stewart said there
was nothing she could do
I should go subscribe to Howard Stern I
know where I live have a car I don't
know I think an app I think you could do
a serious app okay but like can't I just
get he needs a podcast using YouTube
channels something patreon whatever
he tried wait um this is just like
really sad and depressing because as a
Twilight Stan and actually we were
really talking about this last night
Margot was ssangshik a BuzzFeed quiz
about like her Twilight knowledge and
she actually was like considered a
number one Stan we were [ __ ] obsessed
with Twilight and the fact that they
were together jury and then no Howard
Stern says it's a mistake but the fact
that they were together through all five
movies like really made it different
like it made it so special and like when
they got married you know they were like
really thinking about like when they
were getting married like it made it it
elevated it I'm sorry elevated and
equally sure even with the kissing booth
like the fact that I knew right before I
watched movie that Joey King and Jacob
already were
dating I was like oh like the and you
could watch them fall in love like it's
so cute
right and that's like The Notebook Ryan
Gosling Rachel yes if you're watching
love story and I totally agree that is
that the last ingredient that makes a
great romance movie so even if it's fake
like I kind of get it like it's a
commitment nobody it's nothing no no I'm
saying but like there are some people
didn't work out yeah or no there are a
couple times where people have been like
forced to write like Shawn Mendes and
that wasn't it oh yeah yeah 400 for the
song um but do you still think they're
fake I don't know they really toned it
down which means I think that it's real
now right or they just like tired yeah I
don't know this is just so sad because I
maybe now think and I definitely thought
for a while that these two were fake no
I never did but absolutely but I thought
she would look back on and be like oh I
was young that wasn't really real we
were just like caught up in them in the
Thames yeah but she's looking back on it
like no that was like so strong I'm glad
that that she reflects on it in a
positive way because I feel like she's
that kind of emo and like would like
hate it I watched her that episode of
Jimmy Fallon that I showed you about
that was eye-opening yeah she was the
guest and she was eye-opening too
because she is so boring and like
literally didn't speak but maybe that's
just Jimmy being a bad host like Howard
really brings it out in people
he really does and she also said that
like this is the first time she's really
talking about it because for so long she
wasn't allowed to say what happened
right which is just crazy now I have to
listen to this interview I think that of
all the movies I've watched and all like
the weddings I've seen if I could
replicate any wedding for my own wedding
it would be Bella and Edwards in his
house in the race and like they gave us
I mean those song a thousand years
already exists you know it did it like
in my mind but they did the Steve Kazee
version Jenna Dewan was good and and it
became a wedding song also that whole
soundtrack I actually bought the
soundtrack on iTunes like there's so
many songs in there that are just like
Breaking Dawn Part 1 is like I think the
best movie in this series that are
number one or number two
I Breaking Dawn Part 2 is great where's
the one with the newbies that are all
young that's the last word I only saw
that once and then I never saw it again
Breaking Dawn Part two Renesmee the kid
like that's good but it's it's whatever
in the battle I like that one I like
that one too where they have their
honeymoon they finally get to have sex
because in cheats the chicken yeah or no
that's part two when when she wakes up a
bam bam
and they can finally have real sex
that's part two yes part two because
like hehe didn't want to get too like
horny with her the first time because he
would eat her but now she's a vampire
and can't be eaten yeah
Oh part 1 & 2 were so good it's so rare
when she gets pregnant
yeah but then also the weird thing in
part 2 when like Jacob imprints on
Renesmee who is like a fetus at the time
like or no but that one was kind of like
hard because when she was like pregnant
like so so skinny I'm so free it was
hard to watch
she used to watch those special effects
where those like extra content they had
at the DVD where they would show you how
they made her look so skinny and like
gaunt while also having a baby belly and
like was like half press set when she
fainted it was a prosthetic oh my god
the pointers mine but then at the end of
the movie very Jon Snow Jon Snow show
that from Twilight she's laying there
dead one two open movies over you know
her I remember seen their writers yeah
so well done I still Breaking Dawn Part
1 and when I was in NYU student at
midnight with Kristen McNamara and like
we were both crying like I sort of like
it was such a great night that was such
a good times I feel so distant I know
like we haven't had a franchise like
that
I guess Hunger Games just recently I'm
sorry hunger games was good don't get me
wrong
great but like the like I wasn't living
for like the romance like I was living
for PETA for PETA I can't believe she
ended up with PETA she couldn't stand
him and Peter was a [ __ ] okay in the
words of kellyjohn a dork and a twerp
like he was so like little shrimpy like
no Liam would die for her I agree but
then like Liam got a little crazy the
way and it makes people crazy it wasn't
a perfect ending it wasn't a perfect
ending but it was great it was a great
series
you know it's happy ending Peter wait
speaking of I'm like okay Ethan finals -
are you ready I guess it's a little his
news is brought to you by literally one
of our favorite businesses cent bird
literally they've given us so much he's
given us so much here at the morning
toes seasons are changing we're moving
into more autumnal maple based sin and
if you need a new fragrance or you just
I've never been one of those people who
like really has like a smile you know
like no but now you do have an operation
you like everyone know she wears Nina
like you know like Oh
be one of those girls like smell them
from a mile away like oh you're like
Danny's here right at the party or like
she slept in my bed and then it's like
Oh Danny was here I miss her
yeah did you know that scent is the most
powerful since you have actually didn't
know that and faeo taught me that a
smell can bring you a flood of memories
influence your mood and of course
enhanced or natural style with simpered
you can have great taste and mix up your
fragrance between without breaking the
bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci reverse ace
scent bird calm keeps you smelling good
month to month
I have tried Dior from simpered a bunch
and also a boo Gauri likes oh right I
love the Bulgari that's my traveling
scent because I bring my scent Kurtz
with me and I actually wear more perfume
when I travel now because I have Sanford
right is when I'm at home
send Burt is a luxury fragrance
subscription service for perfumes and
colognes they more than 600 designer
brands for you to choose from there you
can choose the perfume you want they'll
send you a 30-day supply which is very
travel friendly so that's why it's great
and it comes in this great little
canister
if you're not sure what type of scent
you're looking for you can sort and find
your new fragrance by brand style
occasion season and more plus day
products and other categories like
skincare wellness and makeup that carry
brands like Coke re which is one of our
favorite natural brands here they also
have Tarte glow recipe glam glow many
others and we've an exclusive offer the
link is different than the last one
we've gotten so please pay attention
please with an exclusive offer just for
our listeners you can get 30% off your
first month today that's only ten
dollars for your first fragrance go to
scent bird comm slash steam ste m and
use our code Steen for 30% off so that
scent bird scen t-bird dot-com slash
teen ste and and use the code Steen for
30% off a scent Burt calm slash Steen
for you to try your first perfume or
cologne for just ten dollars sign on
smell amazing
it's 11:11 make a wish I wish to sign on
and smell amazing for all years of my
life and I wish you have an amazing 27th
year in this world thank you I hope that
I have an amazing 27th year as well
filled with health happiness and steamy
vibes always yeah because when vibes are
seen e means everyone's having a good
time when the vibes are yeah I was a
sweating the vibes have seen the rest o
matter gather pink we ever discuss on
the show that Mara Mars Park
I thought we did yeah we did because we
said that we knew oh yeah oh okay well
I'm happy for her know that I am also we
didn't talk about kissing my scripts
Christmas special with special guests
fred armisen kendall Jenner Rockettes
yeah yeah
I'm so [ __ ] excited music well how
does Camila Cabello get everybody in the
whole wide world whoever the manager is
I want her oh yeah you need them you do
I'm so excited for that this holiday
special it's like just what we need in
KC is oh it's not like people do
Christmas like to be trendy they just
like released a Christmas song cuz I
think they should but like KC has been a
Christmas stand for years she really
stood Christmas album after her
sophomore album we were like all waiting
for the third she took like two years
off and did a whole Christmas tour which
like was annoying but I lived for it
anyway um so she's not just one of these
bandwagon Christmas her know she has a
catalog of her Christmas albums amazing
field when she's who Christmas albums
actually filled with covers and original
songs like Christmas makes me sad like I
feel you Christmas at Graceland or
something no that's the movie yeah yeah
good stuff okay yeah final story CBS
starts delivering prescriptions to homes
via UPS drones it could help people who
can't visit the pharmacy himself that's
nice so I just really deliver drones not
everywhere but in New York pharmacies
dodol it and there's that app caviar I
know you have fun there's a lot of
things but like drones are in the future
drones of the future I've been hearing
Amazon has been using drones but I've
never actually like seen one being
delivered definitely can't use them in
New York you know cherry yeah but it
didn't take long for UPS in CVS to start
delivering prescriptions by drone the
two have confirmed that they completed
their first paid home delivery some
prescriptions hauling medicine to two
homes one of which was a retirement
community in Cary North Carolina on
November 1st
the drones flew autonomously and lowered
the packages to the ground with a cable
and winch although there was a human
operator ready to take control okay so
this is like very beta but cool that
we're moving towards the future okay
also back to this con anything someone
came in theory yeah no because I just
realized that the lyrics that that were
leaked online I did look them up they
were different than the lyrics said I
got the lyrics I got were correct yeah
because he obviously changed a song when
he was
Allen like a month earlier um so while
most lyrics were the same there was like
two lines that were completely different
that he changed and no one would have
known that unless it was someone from
actually Z's house so legitimate [ __ ]
sheet music that we shared
you got actually Z's like the whoever
supposing this is just [ __ ] cold man
this thirst monster of the worst kind
silliness let's recap real houseless
Marg County I think of silliness um what
a great [ __ ] episode like finally the
pieces are being put together I was a
little dismayed because I went on
Instagram afterwards and like a week ago
Shannon Tamra and Vicki like all went on
a trip so it's obvious ed whatever is
going on between Tamron chatting like
doesn't stick okay but it really is like
at the end of the day it's all Tamra and
I cannot believe it took us this long
for Kelly to finally know that Tamra was
the one who brought up training and
blaming Vicki this whole time a hundred
percent it really is all Tamra and
everything that she's doing and maybe
she is trying to keep like the show
going but she really is being such a
[ __ ] starter and what's so crazy is
Bronwyn who liked to me was the
spineless one she is the one who is
responsible for the takedown and like
she's spine full I'm really feeling like
she's Michigan to herself she's like
she's learning as she goes how to handle
she's gonna be situation and know and
now like I don't feel like she's finally
said I like she stands up for the things
that are important to her and it's
paying off at the beginning of that
episode where Vicki unaware Tamra Kelly
and Shannon all went to lunch and they
basically painted a picture that was a
complete [ __ ] lion Shannon didn't say
anything because Shannon knows the truth
Tamra sat there and was like we were
defending you Broadman was talking [ __ ]
about you when everyone was talking [ __ ]
about Kelly except Ron when Bronwyn was
the one defending her like that was
infuriating to see Kelly get so mad and
called Brahmin who was like spending
time with her family to get gelles out
and shut her crying on the phone like
that was injustice that was such
injustice and like Bronwyn was talking
about Kelly but she was diffusing what
everyone likes that was a crazy
situation like Tamra committed so many
and justices in the past two episodes do
you Inc like mean things and then lying
about it and pinning it on other people
and and then we shaded lis talking [ __ ]
about Shannon everywhere wait that's so
crazy because they didn't show it until
the end but when they were at that lunch
they Shannon got up toward the bathroom
and Tamra like spokes [ __ ] about her
being like it was all Shannon
and then that text message was kind of
crazy because even though Tamara didn't
say anything she sent the video of that
woman fake getting hit on the head which
by the way is hilarious and while she
didn't say anything like she would only
say that no I think that's why is Chuck
yeah no so crazy like I cannot believe
there was so much footage of Tamara
being like a little sneaky and it wasn't
put together until now no and I'm glad
the chickens are coming home to roost
I like Tamara has always been a favorite
of mine and even her enchanting but when
her and Shannon were at that lunch with
Kelly I was like oh these girls are
disgusting but you know what Shannon
didn't say one thing no but like not
saying anything and letting these like
letting Kelly bark at Bronwyn I'm like
that's not a friend also you know I'm a
Shannon apologist and I defended her in
her worst time he's but like to me that
was her worst time yeah but wait there's
more when they were then at the other
lunch without Tamra and Kelly was like
you should hear this she says about you
Shannon and Shannon's like me and then
she said the week gating thing that's so
crazy because that's only something
Tamra knew no and that's why I believed
it otherwise I would have been like
Kelly she's angry I'm sure like Tamra
has just spoken about Shannon and
Kelly's putting a negative spin on it
like you could do that and she wouldn't
necessarily be lying but it's not like
tamarin talks mad [ __ ] no but if there's
only one thing that if there's a thing
that only one person knows that right
then Geno's Kelly's not lying right
which is feels like we automatically
knew Kelly wasn't lying and then next
week Tamara tries to put it on Shannon
[ __ ] is crazy okay and then also I just
want to talk about one second I'm Emily
in a bathing suit because I thought she
looked really really great I thought so
too and the fact that she was at Eddie's
gym and he told her she's considered
obese like when I saw her I mean I said
like no she really has a rockin bod
animating suit she looks better in a
bathing suit
people who's like tight yeah she has a
great booty yeah I just thought she
deserves a little justice after sitting
through that meal with Shane I was
trying to go with a bread basket like I
could have stopped him across the face
no I totally agree and this week I was
like sad about chain again when I was
starting to feel hopeful like maybe he's
just like he just doesn't come off well
on TV but now she said crying in her
testimony I was like it's not good no
but you want to watch I was I've
recently in real-time and said that
they're not getting divorced oh it was
actually a really good episode
Gina continues to be one of those
annoying people on the planet who's like
sucking Tamra's dick like and on watch
happens I blessed him with come Kurama
like she was being even bigger
dick-sucker like everything he says is
amazing like she's
finally like been accepted into the
group and after being an outsider like
she doesn't want to let that go and
she's being such a loser like she is now
spineless I officially give the crown
from Bronwyn to Gina yeah and I'm sure
that Gina um like Gina's the only one
who's gonna have Tamra's back like as
she goes through this and it's like but
without that they could finally take her
out not even take her out I don't want
her to leave the show but like you just
need to be knocked down like realize
what you did it and apologize and and
just do better total like when you have
someone who's like now it's just two
sides of the group mhm it's you're not
gonna get that justice um also uh I
don't care about her Matt sorry I just
had to put that out there like I don't
care no me neither especially because we
never seen him we don't know him we
don't know what he looks like like how
am I supposed to be interested the grade
um I have a little birthday surprise for
you um it goes a little something like
this yeah just bring it happy birthday
that's really good that was your happy
birthday happy birthday just like the
middle one it sings this is such a
beautiful go back is there there's a I
think a little button on it sings the
candle sings oh my god I was a [ __ ]
expensive candle cake for a trendy girl
we want to wish you a happy birthday we
hope you have a wonderful 27th year on
this planet we are so grateful you're
alive like we don't know where we'd be
probably on the streets yeah we love you
very much and we hope you enjoy your
cake love you thank you guys and they go
for the birthday wishes so far it's been
a great morning
make a wish now make it a good one and
don't tell anyone happy birthday to you
happy birthday to ya I'm just gonna go
for one of the balls yeah she's she's on
the CMA diet I'm on a CMA diet I nailed
down my dress and it's so [ __ ] tiny
like everything by the way this is a
very trendy cake
that everyone in New York is success so
that I just say it's terrible it's my
least favorite cake it tastes like sour
cream no it's really good but it's
really really sweet but it's cute
I'm gonna take some pics with it any
last words on your birthday show um
thank you all for being toasters letting
me live out my dream and makes every
year better than the next and if you
want to like tell a friend to follow me
on instagram that'd be dope
it's a greatest gift of all or subscribe
to the patreon page share not calm
session morning toast we love you guys
so much thank you so much for this
name's the morning toast money a morning
show where we go live money to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube feel
free to give this video a thumbs up
subscribe also available as a podcast
pretty much anywhere podcasts we found
so that's iTunes Spotify stitcher Public
Radio I our videocast box subscribe over
there leave a five star review but how
beautiful selling and smart we are we
love you guys so much it's my last show
of the week snitches filling in for me
tomorrow and then meet the special yes
we got snitch on the tozi the special
co-host friday keep up with me on my
Moroccan adventures um plug with no job
I love you guys so we have so much
content for you guys with tienen right
now a new episode of mood before and
Elizabeth is out today new episode of
the snatchler is out yesterday it's all
about her life in the big city a new
episode of date night came out on Monday
so there's just so much content head
over you have no excuse we love you
you